I'm gonna show some stuff that actually
used to show years ago whenever I had a
chance like teaching chess or something
I'm gonna show one of my games that I
played in 2001 a long time ago and I'm
gonna show this some some some studies
or a-to-z they're called so first of all
these are just for fun I'm gonna kind of
run through them pretty quickly but then
we'll I'll show you this game because I
haven't shown any any of my games since
I've been here so I figure okay I get my
chance to show one one game that I want
okay this is this is a study by someone
named Kazan Civ and it's white to play
so this one is a little hard of a hard
solution to find but it's really amazing
so to start off with black his up a
queen for rook and Knight let's say rook
and Knight right the white has something
going for him do you see any way to make
use of this one factor which at the
moment is worth something
any ideas kind of yeah but besides that
Anand yeah u6 we can use that right so
maybe push it
good check on a three well okay that's
what why should you I mean this one's
hard to talk to you what push the pawn
and he checks so white doesn't have to
lose the pawn though Yeah right what
could he do
block with the rook right
okay black still he needs to take that
pawn or otherwise it's gonna Queen check
okay
fixed upon black better take the pawn
right and now suddenly got all these
pieces here on on the fourth-ranked all
lined up and White's done I'm just gonna
show you the solution this cuz it's
really high it's kind of silly for me to
just ask people for advice here start
off with this smooth forking the king
and the Queen right black better take
tonight yeah we do it again for King the
king and the queen has to take it so it
got rid of those two pieces we didn't
need them they were in the way and now
we check here that discovered check with
the King and blacks only way out of
check that doesn't lose me who's the
queen and everything else is this if he
goes Bishop f4 then I suppose white
takes right black has to take if he goes
King here and then this and then we take
the Queen right they would chase the
King away from the Queen and so he has
to take
and then what he takes back and here we
have King and pawn ending but who's
winning here
I mean whites winning right and black
black can't his king is badly placed to
three pawns against two is gonna be a
win anyway but there's nothing black can
do he's got two legal moves g5 and King
G for it because g5 an f5 we promote the
pawn because King g4 then we got King g5
and still nothing's nothing's happening
Plex gonna run out of moves soon for
instance here here here here here you
know here so on when should we take this
pawn so that that's that's not gonna
help black so the only thing he can do
is King g5 right now what do you think
why does h4 okay King here King has no
moves
does anyone see that it's made in three
moves
this is involving blocking flight
squares
our position is more for King and pawn
endings not not so much but it does it
does help us to control some squares at
the black king is yeah so you're queer
yeah but black has a chance to say
something too then he goes Queen e5 and
then whatever
efore you for then black could go here
b5 okay good idea get the Queen back but
at the cost of black remains up a bishop
so that's not quite it
any other ideas you got a forcing moves
obviously that's what makes it a lot
easier to solve this position because
you're down a queen plus black has a
whole bunch of checks so there's really
no question of making any quiet moves
here we've got to just look at checks
work b1 doesn't work it's too quiet
look f4 okay we're starting to get there
okay black has to take it right g4
I bet the King takes all right
not pawn takes though what happened to
fajn takes e4 so now does that give us
an idea
from this position Rick f4 doesn't work
because Bishop takes g4 King takes g4
first has to take it right with a pawn
and now look at 4 and then 4 ok so
that's this that's this this study now
let's see this this one this is this is
funny ok it's white to move what's white
and what's you know I mean what's going
on here
yeah but what about this pawn no Bishop
g7 okay let's see so I go here if you
take the rook I just make a queen right
and then it's not gonna be able to too
much
so right now blacks up the exchange and
has this pawn and f3 but White's got
some pawns and blacks very cramped over
there with the king and the rook so what
do you think why I could do any other
candidate moves here okay Bishop c5
stops the pawn and now black is gonna
take here's all right and it's only a
white fighting to hold but it's not even
probably gonna go hold right because
blacks about to start pushing this pawn
and it's gonna be faster also you can
take here on each six white tries to
defend h6 then they can still take right
because if the bishop takes than f2
any other possible moves away
yeah one to g7 that's so that's obvious
move to try ready because we've trapped
the rope look at that and some black
goes up to
now
okay take the rook with
still about to make a clean all right
white can't get to g8 it's a light
square and you can't he doesn't have any
he could try King f7 but I'm planning
Bishop g7 made but unfortunately black
Queens with Czech so it's not that it's
not going anywhere though does anyone
see some idea to set something up Bishop
e7 what's the idea with Bishop e7 yeah
go to f6 so well black has basically one
legal move I mean why yes
for legal moves right but there's you
don't get any advantage by making
different piece you have to make a queen
right nothing else was gonna we'll see
that but
okay so Bishop of six of the idea looks
bad for black about to take that rook
black is unlucky because this pawn here
there's no checks but suddenly what do
you think black does here
any ideas there's only one move that
black can even hope have any hope
and which pawn are the Queen e2 or
something then white takes the rook
anyway and makes it yeah you do this no
checkmate
but is there any other move black could
player he just resigns take the bishop
what is way to it happen
hey wait takes back what is black do
looks like a bad position for black
right it's a stalemate
so does black so does white take back
take the rook if the King takes if King
takes then of course white takes there
no stalemate and we make a queen and
what so I mean okay the Queen takes
right blacks up a whole queen so it's
way to here
kingi 7 the Queen takes e5 in black d4
so I mean before we look these you know
and see that this is because otherwise
you could just take and make a draw but
now you're down a queen but suddenly
suddenly black is uh this is what's
known as su Guang right black has no
moves I mean he has to move but he has
no good moves so obviously if black
takes the pawn white wins easily you
know we're gonna promote this poem to a
queen and blacks only hope is to do this
because he can't skip a move if black
could skip a move everything would be
fine you know you would have to keep
skipping moves after king e7 but why
can't push his pawns or it'll let the
Queen out right but he can't skip a move
so only try would be something like this
so that after white takes the Queen
black does that now what is way to
because it's a race now
d 5 well let's see what happens after
that like pushes obviously right we
don't need this pawn d6 yeah yeah well I
mean why doesn't lose the race but he's
gonna they're gonna clean at the same
time then and then black is gonna have a
bunch of tracks so these six aged 3 D 7
H 2 da H 1
clean aged between f6 and probably black
has some maybe White's meaning but I
don't know where the white King is gonna
go to get out of maybe late swing I
don't know but there's it was better to
start with the more advanced pawn right
King is blocking it but the thing is
we're gonna clean with check though once
we move our King out of the way so
they're both gonna take the same amount
of time to get up there right this one's
could take 1 2 3 4 moves this one's
gonna take 1 2 3
I mean 3 moves and then the Kings can
have to move and then for the
differences this is with check the other
one the King's gonna be in the way so
that's why we push these six black has
no choice but to put push this pawn and
then then we just move out of the way
and wait Queens would check and then
easily you know gets behind the pawn and
wins so that was yeah I was gonna show
this game which I played long ago I mean
I could pickle all kinds of different
games but I picked this game which I
don't think I've shown I mean ever
really this was from 2001 and the world
open and my opponent was named Gregory
Bray Loski is just 2285 fidei and it was
like 2,400 player for us rating of
different ratings at this time of it so
it was the last round and I began with
efore and he went c5 so who knows what
opening is Cecilia okay so Knight f3
knight c6 and I went Knight c3 so I
don't remember why I chose this move
order it doesn't make
different I could go d4 probably I was
trying to avoid something like I don't
know what I was I avoid basically avoid
this one you meet 85 right but on the
other hand I allow dragon if he wanted
to
did I just okay
I allow I allow this which now I don't
have c4 so I don't have a Roxy bind if I
want to but okay I didn't care whatever
I also allow a 5 which is another line
but you know he keeps me from playing d4
but he weakened some squares d5 but okay
he just chose to go d6 and he wants to
go into open Sicilian and now I don't
have any profitable way to avoid playing
d4 so I played d4
okay so both players kind of you know I
mean I tried to avoid something I don't
remember what he tried he and he was
perfectly happy go into exactly what I
wanted to go into takes Knight takes and
he went east 6 so who knows what opening
this is
it means two pawns on e6 and d6 in an
open Sicilian which is called I mean
this is a Scheveningen basically there's
you know just with the knight on c6
instead of f6 if we had this knight back
on back here on the other night on f6
you've seen that before but it's gonna
be it's the same thing but now g4
Chara's attack doesn't make as much
sense because there's no target on f6 to
attack with g5 so he's trying to avoid
that type of thing okay I just did off
my Bishop to e3 okay
you a knight of six Queen to d2 so the
idea is I'm about to Castle queenside
and play f3 and g4 and start pushing
pawns this is a setup which you can use
in a lot of openings this is a called
the English attack here it's it's also
against the dragon somewhat different
but same idea you Castle queenside you
go f3 you go g4 h4g v h5 and push those
pawns over there and meanwhile you keep
the center solid enough with f3 okay
so I'm starting off with this move maybe
if I went f3 right away he could do
something like d5 so I want to just I
want you know get castled right away and
I wasn't too worried about Knight g4 but
he played that anyway no Knight g4 I
think this is a wrong move but you know
this was against like thirteen moves 13
years ago and even masters they've made
a lot more mistakes early on in the game
it was a lot less information out there
but here for instance better to just did
not play Knight he's trying to exploit
the fact that my that I didn't play f3
early on but he missed something he
wants to take my bishop and I don't want
to let him take the bishop it's better
for black to just keep developing here
for instance and if f3 you know we can
do this type of thing takes Knight here
and it's complicated game but okay so by
the way ask questions if you have any
questions but he went a g4
okay so I don't want to let him take
that bishop that's an important piece so
I went here I know queen is under attack
what does he want what does he do
yeah he went Queen b6 and now I went
here and his idea was probably to play
this move what do you think I would do
here Knight a for suddenly blacks queen
is trapped because it can't go back
these destroyers were covered and Queen
a5 will that results in the Queen being
traded and then I and I'm gonna do what
here what do you think I do work the
rook and Bishop with night c7 right okay
so I did look at 94 obviously I have to
check what happens after this it kind to
ative Lee doesn't look right but the
idea is we trade Queens now his knights
under attack but so is mine so this is
what I plant nicer seven King G said
when I take the rook well he has to take
my rope okay already you can reject this
for black because this Knight is trapped
and my Knights not really trapped but
now I have also checked he has to go
here and then this okay so so that so he
saw that he couldn't play a six and
Knight a four is nevertheless a big
threat whatever he does 94 it's gonna
chase the Queen away from Guardian c7 so
he played a smooth clean a5 ok the Queen
moved twice but maybe my knight will
have to be chased back it's on b5 he's
gonna go a6 and it's you know so that's
what he hopes okay I played this move I
suppose I could I I look I probably
looked at this but then he gets a big
lead and development idea is that if he
takes this Bishop Knight b5 I think I
got this idea was check on c7 yeah I
can't stop it because I mean even if he
makes her first King to get away that's
made right now but if he makes room for
his King to go wait I'm still gonna take
to rook but I think I didn't like just
he plays this move and
my bishop has to move away and then he
starts getting lots of counter play with
with you know this type of thing I I
mean I don't remember how much I went
into this but you know I also I was I
was 21 I just like to attack you know I
didn't I didn't want to grab that pawn
so I wanted to bring more pieces out I
think I didn't fully look at that Knight
takes D 6 so much but it probably wasn't
right anyway so I went Bishop you to
just I want to get my pieces out now I'm
threatening the knight on g4 okay he
goes a6 so what am I gonna do here
should I take his knight and make him
take my knight and double the pawns this
is gonna be like is this gonna be bad
double if I take here is this gonna be
bad doubled pawns for black yeah now now
suddenly b4 is coming and the open a
file is actually pretty strong the
double pawns aren't great but black has
a lot of dynamicism here so I'm not so
sure that's a good idea
so of course I retreat my knight yeah
okay I also have this again but this
time Queen takes the g5 is hanging so
white would have to take here mmm just I
think I didn't even consider this is
clearly better for white I mean this a
pawn up right and black has a little bit
of play but not a whole not enough but I
mean with his Queen moving twice going
to a5 the knight jumping around I wanted
to gain time so I just I just did this
because I realized his knights under
attack and I'm about to bring my Knight
to c4 with tempo so I didn't want to go
grabbing the pawn maybe it was a good
idea but and I didn't want to do that
I'm about to go Knight c4 with tempo
attacking the Queen this is gonna be
under attacked and this also meanwhile
I'm threatening tonight so I better so
you better to deal with a knight so he
went he was here and now I chased the
night
so this is why I didn't want to grab the
pawn you know he got some counter play
at this time I get my I get the attack
he went here my HC for attacking the
Queen he goes there it looks like it's
been going really swimmingly for white
so far but it's not that simple because
black has a counter threat h6
he wants to trap my bishop and that's
not easy to deal with you know each six
this Bishop is you know if it was here
terrible for black but also he has b5
coming perhaps and that's gonna attack
this and gain time and then it'll look
like my knight moved g1 F 3 d 4 b 5 a 3
c 4 and now again somewhere maybe so
that he lost a lot of time but also my
my knight moved about five or six times
but still i have the lead in development
i just have to be consistent here so I
played f5 I have to do this to save my
dish of but my and giving up the e5
square so now he's gonna get that square
for his Knight okay I keep developing
important to castle and get developed
and he did this move so now I had a now
this is where I thought for a while I
remember was a long time ago but
basically I think I was a little bit
wrong I mean I didn't quite understand
how much human advantage I had basically
like I take stakes I didn't like this
because it takes you know he's throwing
in a check there where he could take
right away whatever but and then taking
back and it looks pretty good for black
right you got pieces out and everything
still it's probably actually better for
white after 95 because black really
doesn't have any control of the d4 but
White has a d5 and blacks bestest he's
gonna have to give up the bishop or
something but still I felt I could do
better than that I don't know if I
really looked at that so much I just
didn't want to let him species out I
could also consider to not take on e6
and played this and then I was I didn't
probably like some you know this pawn is
a real serious problem for black why
it's also better there but what I did
was I said okay I want to take on e6 and
find out how he's going to take back if
he takes to the pawn then I'll happily
take care because if he takes to this
pawn this is terrible
you know I'm gonna put my bishop
somewhere over here or check first and
then come back and it's it's an awful
position he's not going to castle it's
just terrible meanwhile if he takes
the bishop then I'm going to come here
now that he's decided I'm not gonna take
on e5 I'm still gonna come here and then
I'm gonna come in to d5 with one of my
Knights and that's also terrible for
black so I wanted to play forcing way
now there's a little issue that my own
Knights under attack but I was willing
to sacrifice a piece so that's what I
did and he surprised me with something I
didn't even consider he took on c4 he's
winning a piece of different way after
this I thought he would take with a pawn
but then the idea was I take I go here
my knight penis to move and then I just
take this pawn back and I've got two
pawns for the peace and his King is
stuck in the center with open F file the
bishop on this diagonal opened e-file
Bigley in development and I think White
has a big advantage here but that's you
know I mean I just wanted to play this
position I wasn't thinking so much who's
better or whatever but it's it's I just
looked I mean probably should do that
though so he took on c4 this led a lot
of practical problems because it looked
like really bad for black but there was
a lot of different possibilities for me
so here if he takes there I just go here
and this is this is not what black wants
right I mean he can't castle this Bishop
is aimed at the weak point on e6 and
it's tough for blacks so he does this
now what do you think White's gonna do
here
black is attacking two bishops right I
got a gigantic lead in development his
kings in the center but I still have to
find okay first I do this sorry I mean
95 obviously right you you tack the
Queen the Queen moves away and but still
two bishops under attack it seems like
there there should be lots of good moves
but really it's not that simple
what should wait to hear
okay Bishop f6 yeah we want to sacrifice
something yeah
that's for sure but probably he thought
he takes it you know what
night of six
yeah okay I probably white has a lot of
compensation but it's hmm three fives
and can block maybe he could even yeah
but maybe he could even take that bishop
okay Queen g7 I suppose something like
something like this
it's not so simple I may be also after
Queen g5 maybe he can do this and allow
a discovered sec because there's always
Bishop e7 to block yes there's actually
a lot of good attacking chances here but
it's it's I think I mean I don't just
curious if you're gonna guess the way I
played because there I think the other
ways well they're not so clear at least
you know they weren't at the time maybe
there's some other way that's also
should be several moves that are good
but what else is good way to
sometimes it's hard to play positions
with looks so promising there's lots of
different possibilities and butts here
you know black is gonna be up a piece so
it's very provocative play for black
thing you gotta still solve the problem
anyone so where to move the night - yeah
I mean I take that I mean you can take
on f6 right it's a pretty natural move
and I think this is actually technically
good for white but at the time you know
I thought it takes here and somehow you
know and then white takes the rook and
black takes there I fold with box gonna
Castle and he has two pieces for the
rook no I suppose there's some sort of
tactic with this I don't know exactly
how the saw were it's uh Queen on H King
g8 then here Queenie some takes theory I
don't know it was all kind of fuzzy I -
somehow it's good for white I don't know
but huh Bishop e2 ready to the beginning
so V - okay I didn't consider that one
Kenny can you take here check that's
right here g6 it's not as easy as it
seems to catch black you know and
sometimes he can give up this Queen to
rook f7 that probably doesn't have to I
don't know I mean it's not easy position
for black Bishop e2 is a possibility but
also after Bishop e2 I mean that maybe
you can even just capture the pawn and
he's ready to castle already check I
guess okay that's good for a white I
guess
yeah I suppose after Bishop e2 somehow
he take we take the bishop and check
here work f7 maybe just take how much
pieces and how many pieces club no
that's not enough
yes I know maybe this one then is very
good continuation night of six and I
have six black and give up the Queen I
can take the knight and then take take
the Queen back probably white doesn't
have anything that's two minor pieces
and a rook for the Queen in this case
it's not enough suppose there should be
seven
all kinds of stuff and here you have
this move you know I mean it's it's it's
easy for someone to get away somehow and
you're attacking but if you miss
something and I can who knows what can
happen I don't know what's going on here
it should be - I didn't consider it
that's interesting what I played was
this move so the idea was well if I
retreat this Bishop simply it takes
rickety look here he has enough pieces
oops 97 is better he has enough pieces
guarding he seven but I took with the
rook now if he now if he just takes this
Bishop of course this time it's
different
there's too many pieces on e7 so he has
to take the rook
after-work f6 that's to take now I take
there he goes he has to get out of the
check so he goes there and I and I do
this check yeah and now if he blocks
what happens if he blocks with a knight
was way too here
Queen a5 yeah and then you know what I
was better than night see sobbing I mean
I see sevens good but there's even
better move Knight f6 you know check me
so he can't block with a night so he
blocks at the bishop or if he blocks to
the bishop he didn't block with the
bishop either if he blocks with the
bishop it doesn't look good in general
but I can also take you know he has to
take right check and then even I saw I
think at the time that I could take he 7
and then Queen c6 check if the Queen
takes but even better is just to build
up attack threatened threatened d8 Queen
d8 mate here blacks up a rook but his
pieces are so bad there's no way to do
anything
I mean Queen to d8 is threatened and
it's just no mobility at all he could he
could take the the pawn for instance but
then then then Bishop takes and it's
just blacks you know about Bishop d7 and
then Queen takes c7 there's no way to
defend his position if the works are
sitting at home you know he's got
material but he doesn't even have
material actually because White has
three pawns for the exchange at this
point but so that wasn't something he
could consider so so he had to go to E
maybe his I think no you offered to draw
earlier in the opening but okay at this
point you know I I wasn't going to take
a draw and there wasn't idea so instead
of instead of repeating positions with
Knight of a for instance knight of six
king dat 95 that would be a draw but I
just brought it the last piece into the
attack rook f1 come down a rook now and
he can take this bishop to I think
that's what he did yeah he took the
bishop what would you play here is black
any I'd anyone see any ideas actually
it's hard to say that there's there's
one thing that I didn't occur to me
during the game there was a very
interesting idea first of all we got to
see what happens if he just in the game
he took the bishop we got to see what
happens if he
takes this yeah because it's a look
right you take that pawn so what do you
think I do here
hmm yeah tonight of six okay King of
seven now probably at the time I just
said okay I take on e6 just to take back
Queen d5 check and okay discovered
checks all kinds of mayhem is happening
here
it's got to be terrible for black and in
fact I think something like Knight g4
check King f8 and then like work f7 is
was crushing I mean I probably die
didn't calculate this for sure I just
looked at this earlier today but this is
this is like III definitely just use
intuition say all these pieces are on
blacks King and you can't take the rook
because I take here and then the only
move would be this and then negative six
hey so but there's so many there's so
many other ways to win here and one of
them was also the simplest of the
clearest is this I guess with the idea
that he if he takes the knight his check
right if he takes the knight I take here
these two bishops are too strong and
there's check here and then check me so
nigth a and probably i could have found
it an f king e8 then i take this which
is really holding blacks position
together even though it hasn't moved and
then take this and you can still see but
during the game i mean you don't you
don't look at this type of stuff you
just say okay all my pieces are
attacking him forget it if he plays it
all figure it out you don't have time to
go fine force mate and ten moves in
every single line you've got to use your
intuition right if he takes the knight
of course queen takes c6 King King g7 or
King f8 Bishop h6 so he goes here you
know and then I take here and that's
just you know if it takes a Knight Queen
e6 and okay so so he he took the bishop
but okay what do you think I do now I'm
down rook in a minor piece so I have to
make attacking moves always so what do
you think
kind of told you already yeah Rock f7
right so rook f7 so now if the Queen
moves Knight C sub and if he takes this
then unlike the variation before the
Queen's not guarded so that says you
know now instead of two rooks in a minor
piece it's rook in a minor piece for the
Queen and I have a huge attack so that's
hopeless so the Queen can't move Knight
c7 so he had the block okay what do you
think I do here if I take with a knight
he's gonna destroy my whole attacking
structure with taking that crucial pawn
which has really been important since
the very beginning that pawn and the
knight on d5 were absolutely just
fundamental to the whole attack this
would break down the foundation of it
and remember blacks got material to give
back a lot of material to give back so
you got all when you're attacking you
got to watch out for those type of
things you know and now you know rooks
under attack the Knights under attack
everything you know so that's it's a
good idea but it doesn't quite work and
that's the same thing that would happen
if the bishop took I guess Bishop takes
c6 as well right and then suddenly you
know suddenly you know there's no so so
after Bishop e7 what else could I do
well remember blacks also got material
to give back and I suppose he could take
heed take the Queen and now he could
throw in a check or maybe yeah yeah
probably throw in the check and then
take the rook right with the bishop
check here so it makes sure that's safe
and the next move after white gets out
of check you could take here a lot of
pieces for the Queen remember it's just
it's a queen but that doesn't mean that
if you have your opponent has two rooks
and two minor pieces for the you know I
just resigning you know so so that
doesn't work what I have to do
I have to keep sacrificing even more so
I take with the rook that's the that
Bishop was a crucial defender if he
takes to the knight what happens
check him here if he goes this way
Bishop h6 check me right so if he goes
this way well Queen a five years Queen
c7 now that Knights on d5 anymore so so
I take d6 he has to block with the
bishop and now I simply take and I'm
down at a look and the exchange but the
positions hopeless for black because
White's pieces are just too active again
small amount of force but pieces but
huge force you know Knight c5 is a
threat
taking e7 as a threat a lot of other
different threats now you know I mean
just you can't find a defense here
looking around you won't see anything
mainly Knight c5 is the biggest threat
but even despite a huge material
advantage for black there's no way out
of this one so so after rook takes c7
okay he gives up his queen right now I
took the Queen and here he's got two
rooks and a bishop for the Queen but
here comes the punchline I don't take
the knight because I mean I don't take
the pawn which is the natural move
because he goes here and how am I going
to get through this I mean maybe there's
a way it looks looks risk
look at this pawn so strong maybe I
could take and then Queen c6 but then
King d8 and I don't know but I saw force
twin so I took the night surprisingly I
mean that night but the idea is okay he
has to take back because if he doesn't
I'm I'm taking this pawn and I have
Queen for two rooks but also a ton of
pawns and opposite colored bishops will
make my attack too strong because you
can't defend on the dark squares so now
what do you think I do
Queen g5 right okay so now he's got a
choice to various choices if he takes
here I'm glad you're here
Queen d5 for King the king in the rook
right
if he goes here
clean up 6 and then the rooks under
attack and if the King goes here it's
checkmate
so after this check there is only one
move Qing Yi right now what do you think
I do
queen h5 yeah these remember blacks up a
lot of material here I got a you know I
got an ensure that I'm gonna win
something Queen h5 again he's got some
choices but King f8 obviously loses to
what checkmate
right okay King e7 also allows that same
check check
followed by there's no checkmate but
push the pawn followed by discovered you
know to Queens so the only move is King
to d8 now what I do
so the point was I forced this king to
da that's going to be important in a
second
so here's what I did I attacked the rook
Queen d5 and you see the reason why I
forced this King to d8 instead of going
immediately to d5 because if he goes
rook b8 what do I do here take the pawn
and now it's check and I win the rook
right and if he goes here which is what
happened in the game because there's no
other move otherwise I takes a look
right now what do I do
I could yeah I probably should I don't
know what I was probably excited that
taking the pawn would have been fine but
the point is after still after King d8
what is okay after King yay what is why
- here
anyway let's just go back one move
because I didn't do that I did another
move which wins but I could have done
the same thing but taking the pawn first
I don't know why I didn't do that
do you see a black Scott to unguarded
rooks right so queen d4 yeah now I mean
I might as well have taken the pawn and
then gone Queen d4 I don't know why I
didn't do that no whatever Queen d4 and
so now one of the rooks is lost so this
was so this was idea I mean give up
first of all this strong Bishop for the
night but the idea is check he has after
each move there's only one move and I
have to throw in this check because
otherwise he had ever up the eight here
and then and then that and now I'm gonna
end up with Queen against you know two
pieces against rook and Bishop and now
it was easy and he didn't resign but the
rest of the game was just okay I brought
my king up i guard that pawn now I start
advancing carded f7 start advancing I
don't care if he takes the pawn because
King and pawn ending is winning if he
takes on e4 I'll just trick give up my
queen I start advancing I push that pond
here you know getting ready to come to
g5 at some points and you know I was
there he took that pawn I took this one
now I attack the bishop in the pawn on
d6 took that of course I could take the
rook if I wanted to and then start
pushing pawns him but I don't you know I
just did that and okay did this one and
you know he Bishop before King F -
there's no perpetual there so he went
back there and then I did that and then
he resigned because I'm about to take
that one so that was that was always my
favorite gaming for a long time when I
was you know so I thought I showed that
and it's thought it was an entertaining
game